we do not rule but we may guide the men
that do
gently
hey guys Pete here today I'll be talking
about House of the Dragon episode 9. the
one where we see what happens when the
piece that was holding everything
together is taken out of the puzzle King
viserys the peaceful is dead and episode
8 did a great job of previewing what's
to come by showing that as soon as he
left that faithful family dinner much of
the Goodwill he brought with him gave
way to mounting tensions between the two
different factions that exist in his own
house his presence and his words moved
renera and Allison towards
reconciliation it did seem like they
might work out their differences but
Things Fall Apart before that could ever
be realized it turns out that a provoked
grandson punching an uncle in the face
is only the tip of this Iceberg and in
episode 9 we see how things proceed now
that the king is dead I really like the
opening sequence where we see the places
where power resides when no one's around
a collection of empty halls and a quiet
room with a the vacant Throne left alone
they're only remarkable because we know
what they represent this evokes the idea
that left by itself this foreboding
object fashioned from the weapons of
conquered foes is just a chair at the
same time the king's glorious walk to
reclaim it Illustrated the power and
authority that can't be separated from
it this exists in his absence and we
know that in his failing Health he had
to relegate that to people he trusted
that proximity gives them tremendous
influence over the succession and in
season one's penultimate episode we get
to see how they use it it starts with an
unnamed boy who takes word of the king's
passing to Talia she takes the news to
Allison who tells her handmaiden not to
tell anyone else based on the late night
complication that she now thinks her
husband changed his mind about his Heir
she instinctively wants to buy time to
figure out how to proceed as things
progress we'll see them confine everyone
who knows about this to the castle so
that they can manage how the news gets
out she tells her father about viserys's
change of heart and it's here where the
show starts to paint its own picture of
how they react and the book's telling
you're led to believe that the high
Towers had been expecting this death and
that they were just waiting to usurp the
throne for aegon as soon as that
happened here we see that Allison's role
is a lot more complicated and that she
did misinterpret what he was saying on
his deathbed she believes it was a dying
wish from a husband who had changed his
mind as they convened the small Council
Tylan Lannister reveals that they had
long laid plans to make aegon King
either way so his last minute Revelation
serves to give them the cover they were
looking for this is something that they
were going to do either way and now Otto
is ready to put their plans in motion he
lays out some of their steps they have
to replace some of the gold cloaks
because they're still loyal to Damon
remember he was in charge of the city
watch and was very popular with his men
Thailand says the Roy Royal treasury
will be split up to protect it from
falling into rhaenyra's hands if it
comes to that as they start to discuss
who their allies are Allison snaps out
of her grief long enough to express her
surprise that this had been going on
behind her back she doesn't appear to
have a clue how ready they were even
though this is something her father's
been telling her since aegon was born
and when she says you were all planning
to install my son as king without me
iron Rod tells her that there was no
reason to Sully her with darkling
schemes and this is a nice setup for
what rhaenys will tell her later when
they speak master of coin Lyman
beesberry is having none of this it's
clear that he wasn't involved in the
planning and he does a pretty good job
of explaining why it goes against
everything viserys wanted while he's
doing that they make the choice of
showing Allison as she struggles to
accept the reality of the situation this
is a fairly glorious speech from a
character that has been with us from the
beginning but but it's safe to say it's
falling on deaf ears in this group as he
gets to the point where he questions if
someone actually killed the king
everyone's favorite Kristen Cole comes
up behind him and smashes his face
against the table and I guess in some
way this is the payoff for having these
mostly useless little balls in front of
them as they sit at this table as his
turns out to be the death of him
in response to the murder Lord Commander
westerling draws his sword and demands
Kristen give him his cloak there's a
brief standoff that Allison is able to
defuse and when Grand maester Orwell
wants to have beesberry's body removed
Otto says the door stays shut until they
finish their business historically this
is known as the green Council that's
where the episode gets its name Thailand
sits back down next to the corpse and
mentions that Storm's end will be a
problem they can't count on Lord boros
Baratheon but he does have four
daughters that are unmarried which
brings to mind a marriage pact the king
is already married but we haven't heard
any word of a betrothal for Eamonn and
we'll see in a bit that aegon has a son
of his own Allison interrupts again to
ask about rhaenyra she's told that the
former Heir cannot remain free to draw
support for her claim when she asks if
they plan to imprison her she's told
that she'll be given the chance chance
to swear obeisance but No One Believes
she'll bend the knee or Damon for that
matter and that leads Alison to ask if
they're planning on killing her which
based on the looks on everyone's faces
they absolutely are Orwell tries to
frame this in the best possible light a
living Challenger invites battle and
bloodshed
Otto says it's unsavory but it is a
necessary sacrifice the queen is
definitely not into this idea and we see
that when she unloads on iron Rod but
she doesn't have a plan for what they
could do instead when she's pressed to
that Otto just goes ahead and issues the
order and westerling takes off his cloak
and refuses he says I answer to no one
but the king and until there is one that
he has no place there then they just let
him walk out and the camera focuses on
Kristen Cole as he considers his life
choices which he should because this guy
is terrible this cuts to Allison and
Otto who go looking for aegon and Elena
tells them that he's not in his room you
get the sense from her reaction that
this is a pretty common thing she's fine
with sitting there and working on a
needlepoint of a spider and having a
conversation with her servant who was
looking after her twins jaharis and
Jahira at least that's what they were
named in the book they don't really give
us any confirmation of their names here
but based on the changes in the opening
sequence it doesn't look like they're
rearranging anything here and as far as
we know she has a daughter and a son at
this point which means that aegon does
have an heir as Alison is trying to tell
her about her father's death she repeats
the line that there is a beast beneath
the boards I still hadn't come up with a
guess that I loved for what this
referred to and I'd heard a lot of
theories that all related to book
spoilers that were promising but I think
they were actually going for what
happens at the end of this episode which
I guess makes sense but it's a little
loose and not quite as exciting as what
I was hoping for Eamon comes in to join
them and Otto goes to meet with aegon's
sworn protector Eric this leads to a
race to find aegon because as best I can
tell Alison wants to be able to see him
first so she can try to get him to agree
not to kill rhaenyra the chase itself
makes for a nice chance to look around
King's Landing and we do get a little
bit of character development for aymond
kind of how he sees his role as the
second son and that he thinks he would
make a better King than his brother
which to be fair we learn as they're
walking around is a pretty low bar
while that's taking place we see that
rainys learns that she's been locked
into her room and that all the servants
that know the king is dead are taken and
put in a Cell so the word about the
King's death won't get out Talia and the
boy who found the king are among them
and Laris is there in his role as Lord
Confessor
Otto gathers the Lords on hand in the
red keep to inform them that not only is
the King dead but that he amended his
wishes he tells them that they swore
their Banners To rhaenyra now they must
pledge them to the Future King most of
them do this without a second thought
but there are some dissenters ladyfowl
speaks up saying she won't renounce her
oath to rhaenyra and there's another
character who says he's not an oath
breaker I couldn't figure out what house
he's supposed to be from Otto won't let
anyone leave before they've made their
choice and he has the ones who won't
bend the knee arrested Lord Caswell who
we've seen a couple of times now is on
the fence but ultimately kneels and we
see that Laris is why watching from the
sidelines and takes note of that the
Cargill twins go into an establishment
where they're forcing kids with file
down teeth to fight each other for
entertainment Sir Eric explains to his
brother that the prince spends many a
night there and he sees it as evidence
that he's an awful person that shouldn't
be king they also see one of his Royal
bastards sitting alone in the shadows
who could turn out to be important later
as they're talking about him being unfit
to rule they're approached by a woman
who tells them that she can take them to
someone who knows where aegon is there
will be a price involved and the person
only wants to speak to the hand Allison
is on hand as the silent sisters prepare
viserys's body to be burned she puts his
crown on his chest and cries over his
body he may not have been the husband
that she dreamed of but it is clear in
this moment that she cared for him
deeply she then goes to meet with
rainey's which is probably the most
gripping Exchange in the episode Allison
lays out all the heartache that has come
come on house valarian as a result of
their loyalty to rhaenyra and Damon she
makes a decent case from her point of
view and the most notable thing she says
is that as women they don't rule but
they can try to guide the men that do
gently I think this is the takeaway
we're supposed to have about Alison as a
character at this point if you think
back to the green Council it wouldn't
really make sense that she was surprised
that they were thinking about putting
aegon on the throne as I mentioned this
is something that Otto's been talking
about since aegon was born and until
viserys's speech at dinner this is
something that she was actively trying
to do I think what the show is going for
is that it's not that she doesn't want
that to happen even though she may have
been wavering on her position after the
rape incident in the last episode but
she wanted to do it without the violence
her main issue here is not that he's
going to be king it's that Otto wants to
kill rhaenyra the subtext for the
conversation that she's having with
rhaenys though is that they need need
her dragon and for this she's willing to
offer her drift Mark for her and her
granddaughters to do with as they see
fit rainey's acknowledges that she's a
little smarter than she thought she was
but crushes her justification by saying
and yet you toil yourself in service to
men your father your husband your son
you desire not to be free but to make a
window in the wall of your prison have
you never imagined yourself on the Iron
Throne these are things that Alison has
no response for and she leaves her there
to think about her offer Kristen and
emancy auto meeting with mazaria she
knows that the king is dead and reveals
she's hidden aegon away somewhere safe
she'll tell them where he is if they'll
pay her and agree to stop the kid fights
we saw happening in flea bottom she
directs them to the hiding place in the
sept where aegon makes it clear that he
doesn't want to be found when they take
him outside Cole and Eamon are there to
try to intercept them they want to take
him to the queen a fight breaks out and
Eric with an e the one who's been making
the case that this is not the person
that he wants to see as King of the
Seven Kingdoms sort of sits it out and
then at the end we see him slip away
when Eamon gets a hold of aegon he asks
him to let him go and says he'll
disappear and you see that Eamonn
understands that this could lead to him
becoming the King instead but Kristen
intervenes and takes him to his mother
and I didn't mention it earlier but
Eamon says he's next in line which he
should know isn't actually the case if
the firstborn were to die then it would
follow his line and since he does have
that air I mentioned earlier jaharis
would have a better claim than Eamonn I
trust that the writers understand this
so I wonder what it is that they're
trying to say about this character
Alison does win the race to secure aegon
and that means that she's in charge of
putting together the Ascension in defeat
Otto says whatever our differences our
hearts remain as one and Allison quickly
refutes this saying I see now that I was
just a piece you moved around the board
while this doesn't bode well for their
relationship after she declares that a
reluctance to murder is not a weakness
she quickly pivots to laying out her
plan for how things will go down they'll
send terms to rhaenyra True terms that
she can accept aegon will be crowned by
a septon in the morning wearing the
crown of the Conqueror and carrying his
sword blackfyre they'll use every symbol
they have at their disposal to help
people remember the ancient strength of
House Targaryen they'll do it as a
dragon pit and everyone in King's
Landing will have to be there to witness
it and this does show an understanding
of what their advantage is this
proximity to the actual Iron Throne if
they can get him crowned in front of
enough people they can make them believe
that he is the king Otto still argues
that if rhaenyra is allowed to live then
people will put their banners behind her
until she returns and this is something
that I'll come back to because I do
think he's right to some extent but I
don't get why he thinks killing her
would solve that problem and not getting
what he wants it's clear that just like
when she pulled the dagger on rhaenyra
he's into seeing this side of his
daughter and even adds the comment that
she resembles her mother in certain
lights to drive that home she returns to
her room where she finds Laris waiting
for her he's found out something that
she should know and before you can even
realize what's going on they enter into
this negotiation he asked if she
wondered how her father found aegon
first to this she sits down on the couch
and without anyone saying anything she
takes off her shoes and presents her
feet for him to see he explains to her
that there is a web of spies in the
castle which he probably found out about
when Talia was in the cells and maybe
more importantly that her father knows
about it he pauses before he reveals
more so that she can remove her
stockings then he tells her about Talia
and lays out a plan that if he kills the
leader then Otto will lose his advantage
and of course this is something that he
can do if she Wills him to she then
begrudgingly puts her feet up on the
couch and turns away while he rubs one
out by the look on her face we can see
that this is not something she does for
fun this isn't sex play that they both
take part in because they find it
mutually satisfying this is the price
that she pays to get this information
it's a little on the nose but I guess it
makes some sense that given his
condition he might have a thing for
healthy feet but what stood out most to
me about this was how routine it all
seemed this is definitely not the first
time they've done it and it's notable
that she knows what she's asking him to
do here and is willing to be complicit
in Murder because he suggested it and
it's not something that she wants to
know more about there's definitely been
some Evolution since the last time they
had one of these kind of conversations
and while I do think that this is his
thing I think there is more to it based
on the fact that she's such a powerful
woman that he can make do this sir which
I only know because I know which one
ends up wearing the book bust into
Princess rainey's room to help her
Escape he's decided that he can't get
behind the crowning of aegon and leads
her out of the red keep on the way out
they passed Lord caswell's body we saw
him get caught on his way out earlier
and now he's hanging there as a
deterrent to anyone else who might think
about following rhaenyra we also see
mazaria's house burning down and a man
in a cloak walking away you can't really
see who this is but I'm assuming this is
one of his tongueless assassins because
it lingered on his Cane with the Firefly
and when you look at this scene closely
you can see what looks like that same
pin Eric is trying to get rhaenys to a
boat on the river and she's worried
about leaving melees behind as they're
walking they run into the crowds of
people the city watch is hurting towards
the coronation she gets caught in the
crowd and has to move in the same
direction as Alison is accompanying
aegon on the way to his coronation he
points out the obvious his father never
wanted him to be king he didn't even
really like him he had 20 years to make
that decision and he stood by his choice
of rhaenyra he laughs at the idea that
with his final breath he changed his
mind because to be fair it is kind of
laughable and to that she offers him his
namesake's dagger and you can see the
idea starting to set in for him rhaenys
is relieved to realize that the crowd is
being led to the dragon pit when she
makes her way inside we hear Otto
addressing the crowd he tells them that
viserys the peaceful is dead and in his
final moments he declared that his
firstborn son aegon should succeed him
the ceremony is put together really well
and the actor does a fantastic job in
showing the range of emotions he
experiences as he realizes that even
though this is something that he didn't
want there are much worse things than
being the king when the crowd starts to
cheer and he and she's his House's
ancestral Valerian steel blade you can
see that he's very much into it not that
long ago he woke up under a table in the
sept after a night out whoring and now
he's the most powerful man in the Seven
Kingdoms while this was all going on
rainey's had slipped away and reunited
with her Dragon melees they burst out of
the floor from the lower level and
Scattered the crowd killing at least
hundreds maybe even thousands of them
she's right there in front of the
usurpers they have a stare down where
Allison puts herself in front of the
king and rainey's opts not to give the
commander Karis to burn them instead she
flies away which is amazing looking and
the episode cuts to Black this was a
strange episode which in my mind is a
step down from the last two in a lot of
ways but at the same time some of the
performances were so good that they
overshadowed a lot of the problems I had
I still don't love that a
misunderstanding pushed Alison and over
the edge to get behind aegon but Olivia
Cook delivered so many great moments in
the process of showing how that happened
the episode did work to make the
character more sympathetic in the way
that the previous two did for rhaenyra
and I do think that will probably
increase watchability as things develop
they did a good job of portraying aegon
as awful and unfit to rule while still
giving us some insight into why he
behaves the way he does and as I've
already mentioned Tom Glenn Carney
really showed up for the coronation
scene I also like how there doesn't seem
to be that same love between him and
Eamon as there was with viserys and his
brother which is one of Damon's only
redeemable qualities aegon is a rough
sell for everyone involved including his
mother who has now committed her life to
making sure that he remains in power and
I don't think that we're supposed to
think that gently guiding him is what
this situation calls for I think whether
you like this episode or not will come
down to whether you like the closing set
piece with rhaenys and melees and I
think that's kind of a shame I thought
that it looked great but it also felt
like it only existed because they wanted
to have something major happen in the
closing scene of this penultimate
episode the conversation she had with
Allison was so good and this didn't
necessarily seem like it matched up with
what they were saying I suppose they
were going for the idea that she doesn't
want to escalate the situation like she
has the power to wipe them out which we
know would save a lot of lives and I
know a lot of people are saying that she
didn't want to be a kin Slayer but
they're actively usurping the throne
from your other kin and she did Kill
quite a few of the small folk which I
know is completely consistent with the
way the targaryens think about them but
I feel like this is supposed to be this
dramatic event where she turns the other
cheek or whatever and it just didn't
really land for me also Auto is awful
but he has been portrayed as smart and
careful in the book he takes several
days to methodically set up a situation
that will make the blacks look like the
bad guys no matter how they respond to
it and here he just seemed like a garden
variety bad guy he mentions that her
supporters will call their banners to
get behind her and that's the same
reason why killing her doesn't make a
lot of sense yeah there's no immediate
error there if they kill her and
exterminate her whole family but I don't
think they set it up as a situation
where he thought that he would be able
to get away with that without any
consequences but hey you know what this
is only one side of the story so I do
like that we didn't see the reaction yet
and some of this might make more sense
when we see how that plays out
stylistically I thought it was a great
looking episode I thought the score
added a lot to some of the quiet scenes
and some of the conversations and
overall I think that it may not have
been as good as what we've seen scene
but I'm not exactly worried I'm still
looking forward to see what happens next
and I think that's a great place to
leave things let me know in the comments
what you thought about this episode and
how you feel going into the finale
please like this video If you enjoyed it
please subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already and thanks for watching
I'll talk to you soon